president trump yesterday released a
46-minute video
address from the white house he did not
give the speech to address the
coronavirus pandemic
instead his bizarre rant addressed his
own political problems
where he fueled baseless claims of
election fraud
mr trump called it quote maybe the most
important speech of his life
paula reed has the story if we are right
about the fraud
joe biden can't be president but the
president is wrong
judges in courts across the country have
said the campaign has not provided
evidence of widespread voter fraud
and joe biden is the president-elect
neither of those facts deterred the
president who released the 46-minute
white house produced video on facebook
wednesday
filled with false accusations about the
election we used to have
what was called election day now we have
election days
weeks and months the president's
personal attorney rudy giuliani made
similar baseless claims in michigan
yesterday evening this election was
stolen
by mail in ballots he appeared with
witnesses who weren't under oath
and urged lawmakers to award the state's
electoral votes which mr biden won
to the president instead all i can tell
you is
we let him get away with this i don't
know what happens
after this but the hearing was held in
michigan's state house
not a court of law a judge previously
deemed some of the witnesses accounts as
not
credible just a day earlier mr trump's
own attorney general became the highest
ranking administration official to
publicly dispute the president's claim
and said federal investigators had not
seen fraud on a scale that could have
affected a different outcome in the
election
var reportedly had an intense meeting
with president trump on tuesday
over the attorney general's remarks
undercutting mr trump's fraud claims
the white house refused to say whether
the president still has confidence in
barr
the president if he has any personnel
announcements will be the first to know
it
and while the president and his lawyers
cried foul on the election
the president-elect was focused on the
economic crisis
he'll inherit in january we're likely to
lose another 250
thousand people dead between now
and january mr biden held a virtual
roundtable with people struggling
economically amid the pandemic
this isn't a political game this impacts
on people's real lives and families
it impacts on all of you all of us and
we need to
get help out the door as soon as we can
as millions of american families
families and small businesses
reach a breaking point long-awaited
stimulus relief appears closer to
actually happening
after democratic leaders endorsed a 908
billion dollar proposal that is a
significant concession for the house
speaker who had been holding out for a
two
trillion dollar deal now while both
parties say they are committed to
passing
some sort of package senate majority
leader mitch mcconnell appears committed
to a much
smaller deal gail all right paula thank
you very much